[Music]
Harry giving a shout-out to his ladylove
megan Markel ahead of next month's
wedding and it starts off tonight's
royal report I have incredibly grateful
that the woman that I am about to marry
Megan will be joining me in this work of
which she too is hugely excited to take
part in Megan getting cheers even when
she's not in the room Harry proved his
bride-to-be is always on his mind while
addressing the Commonwealth Youth Forum
in London yesterday the 33 year old was
recently appointed Commonwealth Youth
Ambassador by his grandmother in my new
role I will work to support McQueen my
father the Prince of Wales and my
brother William Harry and Megan have a
busy week ahead of them with several
more appearances set big brother William
will also be on hand without his do any
minute wife Kate but with Megan and
Harry's Royal Wedding 32 days away
excitement's ramping up in Hollywood
last night the Modern Family cast hit up
a preeminent talking all about Megan and
her upcoming I Do's super I'm so
embarrassing she's biracial I just love
that that institution is being
modernized the ROE wedding is coming up
what do we wear I think I would wear
something with less shoulders like our
people bringing back the Larenz a bolero
someone else excited traffic star Paula
Patton did she really foreshadow Megan
soon to be royal status I met her
because she helped me with my wedding
invitations beautiful writing I was like
and knit that moment I feel like I've
said something on her like you are meant
to be like Roy or Vee of this kind I
mean like she's just so graceful and
lovely and actually in really calm
you
[Applause]